التوتر يتصاعد في الضفه الغربيه وفي جديد
المواجهات هناك اندلعت اليوم اشتباكات بين
قوات اسرائيليه وشبان فلسطينيين جنوب
نابلس القوات الاسرائيليه اطلقت وابلا من
الغاز تجاه الشبان خلال المواجهات
المندلعه في محيط جبل صبيح التي يتظاهر
فيها الالاف من المستوطنين للضغط من اجل
تقنين منطقه استيطانيه واعلن الهلال
الاحمر الفلسطيني ان مسعفيه قدموا قدموا
العلاج لمئتين 216 شخصا معظمهم اصيبوا
بالغاز المسيل للدموع اضافه لاثنتين
وعشرين اصابه بالاعييره المطاطيه واخريين
بقنابل الغاز بالراس المواجهات تاتي
بالتزامن مع التن
ظيم الاسرائيليين مسيره للمطالبه بالعوده
الى مستوطنه اقيمت دون موافقه الحكومه في
شمال الضفه الغربيه
مسيره المستوطنين تهدف لحشد الدعم ودفع
حكومه بنيامين نتنياهو الى الاعتراف ببؤره
ايليا تار الاستيطانيه بشكل رسمي وشارك في
المسيره سبعه وزراء على راسهم وزير الامن
القومي ووزير الماليه وهما جزء من الحكومه
الحاليه التي توصف بانها الاكثر يمينيه في
تاريخ اسرائيل بالاضافه الى 20 عضوا
بالكنيست وخلال سيرهم نحو البؤره
الاستيطانيه التي اخليت قبل عامين في
انتظار البث في قضيتها لوح المتظاهرون من
جميع الاعمار بالاعلام الاسرائيليه وبحسب
القانون الدولي تعد جميع المستوطنات في
الدفع الغربيه والقدس الشرقيه غير الشرعيه
ويعيش فيه مستوطنات الضفه الغربيه حاليا
اكثر من
470 الف اسرائيلي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات